Jenny Zigrino, can we
bring Jenny Zigrino back?
Jenny were you in that game,
did you get to see any of that?
I saw it, I watched it.
Look at that butter face.
(laughing)
Adorable.
[Joel] This is a butter face right here.
[Moses] I like that.
What are those called again,
because those dogs like
shouldn't be alive,
it's like against science and nature.
Yeah, against science and nature.
Oh, just like it hurts to be alive.
Those are the best dogs.
Who we got here?
Lupe the pug chihuahua.
Lupe, completely forgive
you for kidnapping now.
She kidnapped him.
I wanted to talk to you guys a little bit
because this is the first
one that we're doing.
Oh look, he's fine.
Look at that.
[Joel] And he's bald.
[Jenny] Dave's fine!
[Moses] This actor made a giant choice.
Honestly, Emmy Award, Emmy Award.
He went bald, he did it.
Dreamy.
I like how he's not even
allowed to sit on the couch
because it's not set.
He has to be in the corner.
You guys, Gary Peterson
is a very funny comedian.
[Moses] Gary!
But are any of us comedians?
No, not anymore.
We've had a rough go at it.
I've been having a real tough time.
None of these shows look
fun that are drive-in shows
or the streaming shows.
Oh, I'm about to do a drive-in show.
Don't say that they're not fun!
It's the only thing
that's keeping me going.
I mean, they're fun for 10 minutes
as long as you don't do
material that you love
and believe in.
If it's just about how
weird it is and the venue,
then you're gonna have the best time.
Great.
So just play the Kim Jong-un game.
Jenny, have you gotten into
any quarantine content shows
that were not so fun?
Uh.
I've done like Instagram Live
shows that are always weird.
I don't like those.
Where the host is over-laughing
just to keep the show moving?
(laughing)
Did you have one where someone broke down?
Someone had a mental
breakdown on one of those.
That was probably the highlight
of all the ones I've seen.
Yeah, they're all a mental breakdown.
Something's not right when
you're able to see yourself, too.
Because people are also like doubting
everything about their facial features.
There's no audience.
It just really pulls the curtain back.
So that leads me to our next game,
which is Canceled
Forever or Second Season.
I'll give you a topic like stand up
and you tell me if it's canceled forever
or it's getting that second season.
So the first one is stand up.
Do you think it's canceled forever.
[All] No!
No, and I will say 90% of
these Zoom shows are awful.
I'll say Jenny and Moses
and I have killed this one.
And I also see other comics.
People are figuring it out.
I think people are
adapting, it's just I'm not
and Moses, you're not.
I don't know how you feel, Jenny, but.
No, I think the less
people do actually stand up
and adjust to the medium that is
what essentially a YouTuber would do,
which is great because comics spent years
talking shit about YouTubers.
And look at us now.
Look at us now.
Everyone's like doing front face
I wish I learned how to edit.
Yeah!
It's like also the TikTok people.
We're all on TikTok now and they're like
we've been here, you nerds.
Are you getting cyber
bullied by tweens, Jenny?
Kind of!
Yeah.
Nine-year-olds comment on videos
and be like you're fucking
stupid, I hate you.
And I go to their page and they're nine!
Yeah, when someone lipsyncs
hate speech it kinda hurts.
(laughter)
So spot on and the
choreography is so great.
Cruise ships.
No!
I think.
Canceled forever?
I love a cruise.
Cruise ships will survive
because old people
still think it's a hoax and they will
force us to come on the cruise ships.
Because your old relatives
force you to go on?
I think they're canceled and then
they will get a triumphant
reboot a la Jurassic Park.
I think they'll go away, but
they're like we'll find a way.
Ships will attack people?
(laughing)
Nature finds a way.
You're a huge cruise head.
You've been on more cruises
than any person I know
that's under 78.
It's true.
You go on fun cruises.
Yes, I go on fun cruises.
Yeah, so how soon before you think
you would feel comfortable
going on a cruise?
I mean, honestly, I'm so low right now
if someone told me to
go on a cruise tomorrow
I would do it.
As long as I know it would get blown up
before it reached harbor.
Just one last, like a viking funeral.
That's how I'd want to go out.
Send me out on a cruise ship
and shoot an arrow into it.
Joel Kim Booster, canceled forever
trying to get a cruise going,
trying to get a comedy cruise going.
Is there anything worse?
That would probably be the
best form of entertainment
Right?
Watch things explode.
Speaking of cruise ships,
buffets in general.
Canceled forever, second season?
You can't keep me away from a buffet.
Man, I don't know.
I think second season, but
you can't touch anything.
Someone else has to
get all the food on you
and then you'll feel a lot
of shame as they do it.
Yeah, so you're thinking of a food pile.
Sort of cafeteria-style.
Yeah, you gotta basically the shame
of you piling on all
this trash on your plate
and they have to do it for you.
I feel like people will travel to Florida
to get that buffet, because you know
that's where they will exist
and continue to thrive.
Absolutely.
Florida is gonna be like
our Sodom and Gomorrah area.
Just that's where all.
That's where anything goes.
Yeah, it is weird because
all these high-risk alerts
are coming out around buffets.
They're just showing infrared cameras
of how much stuff gets sprayed,
that it's a miracle at this point
that we ever even had buffets.
(laughing)
Just the amount of filth that
falls off of people's faces
just for the rare
experience that you can have
lasagna and king crab on the same plate.
Next to each other on the same plate!
Yeah. Have you ever been to a buffet?
He's too classy.
I love it.
Buffets all just about mixing the worst
shit you've ever seen in your life.
It's like a death row.
It's like when you were little
and you would have,
they called it a suicide
where you go to the fountain drink
and you mix all the
fountain drinks together.
It's that with food.
Yeah.
And this is about to turn
into mukbang, this show.
Wait Joel, you're from the Midwest, right?
Yeah, I fucking love a buffet.
You love buffets.
Don't you fucking
I didn't say that about myself.
Moses slandered me and said
I was too fancy for a buffet.
Yes.
Buffets are great.
I think they'll be around
because it's the best way
to break it to your kids that
you're getting a divorce.
(laughter)
Last one, and this is fun
because it's dirty: gangbangs.
Never been invited, sounds fun.
Yeah, those aren't getting canceled.
No.
Yeah, I don't think so.
I think, and lets be clear here,
we're just specifically talking
about gangbangs, not orgies.
Because remember, every
gangbang is an orgy,
but not every orgy is a gangbang.
Oh, please enlighten us.
It's like a square rectangle.
Every rectangle is a
square, but not every,
or every square is a rectangle,
but not every rectangle is
a square sort of situation.
This is how you learned geometry?
Yeah.
Homeschool.
I say, bring back orgies, man.
Bring them back.
Get herd immunity, right?
Get Vitamin D.
If you watch those videos now,
it's almost like you're
watching them nostalgically
when people could be that close.
Yeah!
That's like what you're getting off on,
is just general human connection.
Remember hugs?
Oh, he looks like he cares.
I mean, I feel like as long
as everyone's wearing PPE,
a gangbang could be okay.
Isn't that a hot image?
Isn't that, uh.
Someone in a full mask.
Face shield, yeah.
You put a little hole in the mask,
that should be the next.
I don't think that's one hole
that's necessary in a gangbang.
Yeah, but I'm saying.
Okay, I saw these ones I really like
that were jeans and it zipped.
Just the girl can wear that, or guy,
or person, whatever you are.
Thank you, thank you.
Denim mask sounds awful.
You unzip it, it goes in, fun time.
I like sticking my penis through a zipper.
It's always so calming.
It's always great to have
metal teeth right there.
I prefer to keep it near the zipper, too.
That's how I do it.
Thank you guys so much for being here.
Jenny Zigrino, we can see you where?
Where can we see your touring again?
No.
No, you're on Instagram @JennyZigrino
and you're on TikTok.
TikTok, Jenny Zigrino, that's it.
Follow her on TikTok, Twitter as well.
Yeah.
Also Jenny Zigrino.
We'll put that in the notes.
Joel Kim Booster, new
season of Search Party
on HBO Max, Shrill on Hulu.
Sunnyside on Hulu.
Sunnyside on Hulu,
canceled before its time.
And then Joel you are also
working with an organization.
You're making hygiene bags for people
that are unhoused or homeless people.
Yeah, that was originally started
by Resisterhood LA, which is
an organization here in LA
SELAH, and now I'm only a volunteer,
but Mitra Jouhari, who's
another comedian here
who's based in LA has
sort of taken up the cause
and if you look up Mitra Jouhari,
J-O-U-H-A-R-I on Instagram,
she's always posting
opportunities if you live in LA
and you want to create a hygiene kit
for unhoused people here
or if you want to learn
how to do that in your own city.
Look her up and follow her
and that's what you can do
if you're feeling restless
and want to do some good.
Yeah, absolutely.
Because we have a lot
of time on our hands.
This is a good time to help people out.
Because like one of my friends
said on the phone earlier,
this is all terrible, this is awful,
and it's completely fine to feel that way,
but just know that you are not alone.